as everyone knows it is the tradition at
such campus events to trot out the
proverbial university administrator to
provide the mandatory welcome to the
attendees who have traveled from far and
wide and through wind and storm to
participate we welcome you good morning
today that role and responsibility falls
to me my name is Jim Neal I'm the vice
president for information services and
university librarian here at Columbia
and I extend our welcome to this
research data symposium this event is
co-sponsored by the Columbia libraries
and its center for digital research and
scholarship by Columbia's Institute for
data sciences and engineering and by our
colleagues at elsevier I recall over a
year ago sitting down for lunch just
across from the museum of natural
history with a group from elsevier to
talk about the increased importance of
research data to the process of
scholarly communication and out of that
discussion this symposium was born and
now we have assembled a remarkable
program of speakers and panelists all
organized around the research data life
cycle model which is presented in your
handout in your folder clearly we will
be focused today on the processes of
data creation data discovery and access
data integration and use and data
preservation it is a prodigious set of
challenges that we face but we will also
address the purpose and potency of
managing research data in new and
effective ways how will it advance
scholarship and innovation on a global
scale we will look at issues of policy
particularly during this momentous week
of open access and open data applause
and talk about institutional state and
important national approaches to new
policy development we will learn about
how we are moving from a paucity of good
practice to a heightened preparedness to
manage the very prickly challenges of
research data including important
systemic national strategies and we will
embrace an essential new partnership a
radical collaboration if you will among
researcher funder publisher information
professional and technologist it is said
that every snowflake and an avalanche
pleads not guilty it is our collective
responsibility a few additional
housekeeping items this event is being
videotaped and live streamed on the
symposium website so that we can capture
the conversation and memorialize your
extraordinary insights we ask that
during the Q&A period please use the
microphones which will be passed around
to you where you are sitting posters
will be available for viewing all day on
the second floor directly below this
room one flight down please take the
opportunity to the during the lunch
break to engage with the poster
presenters again welcome to the
symposium I'm now going to turn it over
to two individuals who will provide some
opening remarks first will be David
marks senior vice president for research
data services at elsevier and he will be
followed by Peter Marie rust who is
reader and molecular informatics at the
University of Cambridge and senior
research fellow of Churchill college we
are honored to have both of them here
today